When your dad is on the sports entertainment
Mount Rushmore.
It's gonna be a unique ride.
That's Cody Rhodes right there.
That's Dusty's boy.
He always wanted to be like dad.
To create your own path is extremely difficult.
His NXT kids can be his kids,
but I'm one of his actual kids.
How do you not let him call himself Cody Rhodes?
That make sense?
F***ing maddening.
I knew I had to get out.
If you build it, they will come.
Vince McMahon flew to his house
to get him back.
Not many people can say they did that.
The fresh start for the American Nightmare.
Get a dream, hold onto it,
and shoot for the sky!
This is my one request.
I don't want edited in any capacity,
don't even edit this part.